nathan son petit frère sa maman sont en
martinique depuis juillet dernier
ils découvrent notre carnaval alors
défilé dans les rues de fort de france
une véritable première on y court vite
c'est ça le truc mais non mais ça on va
y retourner ta sont là on a bien aimé la
parade l'autre fois donc on va refaire
d'autres qui mettra peut-être ton
costume d'apparat de martinique ne me
suis pas encore d'église et qu'est ce
qu'est ce qu'on demande à l'école au 7e
rouge et pantalon qui va avec costume de
super héros personnages de dessins
animés et des thèmes bien l'actualité
surprenant parfois enfin 10 pensent
colère on va demander le costume les
sabres on m'a demandé la montgolfière et
on m'a demandé l'art ancien pour moi ce
que j'ai proposé à la mongole chien on a
les boules et l'antenne alors je lui
proposais de costauds musée de
l'ancienne comme ça de faire entrer
l'enfant là dedans et puis le thème
semble sans alors c'était la consume
tout blanc avec un petit peu de bruit
mois les dessus tout simplement ce que
je lui proposais et le cerf-volant
là j'ai pas trouvé le carnaval des
écoles
un rendez-vous bout des milliers
d'enfants tenues accessoires maquillage
l'addition peut facilement approcher la
centaine d'euros
surtout quand on s'y prend au dernier
moment on essaie quand même de leur
faire plaisir puisque
dtm à l'école et autant que faire se
peut on essaie de joindre le budget et
le reste il y à aussi la couturière à
l'ouvragé depuis plusieurs semaines pour
des commandes lié à la tradition pour
petits et grands
des fois les parents sont un petit peu
bousculé qui travaillent qui n'ont pas
le temps d'aller faire la démarche qu'on
est issu donc très souvent à la dernière
minute donc
bon j'essaye de faire pour le mieux un
de répondre aux demandes de tout un
chacun
jour j moins un ou deux pour les
établissements scolaires exemple demain
à schoelcher universal et le lamentin et
la capitale eux ont prévu d'accueillir
les tout-petits vendredi matin